south africa's second wave of covid19
is sending ripples around the world
it's not so much the one million cases
causing concern
but the mutant variant of the virus
that's driving the surge
audrey is taking part in a clinical
trial of a vaccine
but she doesn't know whether she's had
the active jab or a placebo
and worries whether she's protected
this thing is real it kills and let's
just be hopeful that this vaccine is it
and then we might get it free as quick
as possible as
the people overseas volunteers in the
trial are being regularly screened for
the virus the ultimate test on whether a
vaccine is effective against the new
variant
but the first lab tests suggest
antibodies not from a vaccine but from a
previous infection
are 10 times less effective against the
mutant version of the virus
that might make the vaccine less
effective and people who recovered from
the disease
may be vulnerable to re-infection but
doctors
are cautious i think there's reasonable
reason to be concerned
uh should people be frightened right now
we don't know and we're probably going
to have an answer as soon as about
three to four weeks from now about from
the laboratory and possibly even from
the clinical trial
through the course of the pandemic the
virus has accumulated around 4 000
mutations in the spike
protein which coats the outside of the
virus most
don't matter but both the uk and south
african variants of the virus have a
mutation called
n501y in a key part of the spike protein
which makes it easier for it to latch
onto and infect
human cells the south african variant
also has a mutation called
e484k that is causing particular concern
because it changes the shape of the
protein and may evade antibodies
the uk has had two cases caused by the
south african variant
and has stopped direct flights but the
leading vaccine advisor to the south
african government says that won't stop
the virus
and can't understand why the uk is
delaying the full protection of a second
dose of vaccine
to those most vulnerable to infection if
there are these newly emerging variants
around which are more transmissible
what is the risk then if you're only
giving people one dose
greater risk because it is more
transmissible
and your immunity is only half of what
it should be so sure
it's going to increase the risk of
transmission i think the experience
would be a motivation
to go for the double dose the uk
government says giving just one dose to
start with spreads a degree of
protection to as many people as possible
audrey will get two doses in her
clinical trial
and can only hope they're effective
against the shape-shifting virus
thomas more sky news